hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
diogenes of cnope is a very
important figure within the development
early on
of the cynic school we don't really know
although people have different theories
about this whether he
was a student of antisthenes or whether
that's a
later constructed story or whether he
was
the first cynic we we don't really know
and there's some controversy we don't
have to worry
too much about that at this point but we
do know that he
is one of the characters in the
development of what became a very
influential school who was looked to
as a prime example and a lot of people
wrote about him including diogenes
laertes
and within diogenes liertes
there's a discussion among the many
things that he
attributes to diogenes where diogenes
is asked what is the most beautiful or
the best thing
in in the world or for for human beings
uh
kali stone which means the beautiful the
fine the noble
and what does he say parisia
and parresia is something that we
translate
as alternately freedom of speech
or frankness of speech and both of those
are decent translations they kind of
cover
different aspects of this so freedom of
speech
we typically associate with being able
to like
speak your mind and you know
communicate what it is that you want to
without necessarily being
censored or encountering reprisals in
terms of the human being
parisia isn't just a lack of constraints
it's the person's ability to
say their mind they they because you
could have all sorts of thoughts but you
never actually see them because you're
too shy or
too afraid or something like that
frankness
is another nice term because who are we
frank with we're frank with people who
we think
are in some respect deserving of the
truth
whether the truth be something painful
to them as it very often is in the case
of
diogenes and as interlocutors or whether
it's truth that they really
ought to have they have a right to
because they're screwing their life up
oftentimes these go hand in hand right
if you're screwing your life up you
don't like to have other people tell you
that
but this frankness of speech is very
important and diogenes
exemplifies this in the ancient period
among a lot of other people who do speak
their mind and it takes a number of
different forms that i want to call your
attention to
before we go a little bit deeper into
why is he doing this
um he he's said to have poured
scorn on others and
you know scorn is when you're
criticizing
and you're doing so not in a sort of
constructive way
but you know you're making fun of them
uh
plato was you know a prime target
apparently of diogenes but he wasn't the
only target so there's this great
passage
he was great at pouring scoring on his
contemporaries the school of
euclides which is the mergarian school
he called bilius plato's lectures a
waste of time
the performances at the dionysia great
peep shows for fools now that's
theater right and the demagogues the
mobs lackeys
he used to also say when he saw
physicians philosophers and pilots at
their work
now philosophers in the genuine sense
for him
he deemed man the most intelligent of
all animals when he saw interpreters of
dreams and diviners
and those who attended to them or those
who were puffed up with the conceit of
wealth he thought no
animal more silly he would continually
say for the conduct of life we need
right reason or a halter
so he's an equal opportunity offender as
we typically say
and then you know there's some stories
about him and plato observing plato at a
one day at a costly banquet taking
olives and he says
how is it that you you the philosopher
who sailed to sicily for the sake of
these dishes now
when they're before you do not enjoy
them and then plato says nay by the gods
diogenes
there also for the most part i lived on
olives and the like and then
diogenes says well why then did you have
to go to syracuse was it attica at the
time did not grow
olives and so he's he's ribbing him he's
kind of joking with him there's another
great story of him
walking into plato's academy when plato
had to find
the human being as a featherless biped
he plucks a chicken and throws it in and
says there's a man for you plato so he's
constantly
going after plato but he goes after all
sorts of others
as well there's lots of
interesting put downs criticisms
jokes at people's expenses let's just
look at a few
of these to give you a sort of a sense
so in one
great case here we go lysius the
druggist asked him if he believed in the
gods
so he's asking him uh do you do you
think the gods exist or not and he and
so diogenes says
how can i help believing in them when i
see a god forsaken
wretch like you so you know obviously if
if somebody's god forsaken the gods must
exist terrible argument but a great
joke at the time and it's uh you know
conveys something about the guys
character that diogenes is targeting
here's another great one once he saw the
officials of a temple
leading away someone who had stolen a
bowl belonging to the treasures
and said the great thieves are leading
away
the little thief you know so that's
you know a nice little put down right
there
uh in that same section he says when
some boys clustered around him and said
take care he doesn't bite us he says
never fear boys a dog doesn't eat
beetroot any that comes up at another
point as well
what does he mean there i'm i'm a dog
i'm a cynic
kunos right but dogs don't eat crap
dogs don't eat the sort of things that
you nambie pamby
not nobody's would actually be you're
kind of below me so he's using the
occasion
to say something let's look at another
example here
he says that an ignorant rich man he
used to call the sheep with the golden
fleece
uh seeing a notice on the house of a
prolificate to be sold
he said i knew well that after such
surfeiting you would throw up the owner
meaning
you ate too much the house and now he's
going to puke up the
the owner to a young man who complained
of the number of people who annoyed him
by their attentions he said
well don't hang out a sign an invitation
and then a public bath which was dirty
people would go and bathe you know
together he said when people have bathed
there where are they going to go and get
clean
so you know he's got like a witticism
for all these different occasions
they're not necessarily with any great
philosophical content
but you know they they do show some of
his ideas about a few
things uh and what matters in life
um a little bit later here's another
set of things he says um
observing a fool uh tuning a psaltery
a harp right are you not ashamed to give
this wood concordant sounds while you
fail
to harmonize your soul with life okay
now there
what we're seeing is something that
we're going to talk about mistaken
priorities
that he's signaling um he says
to one who protested he was ill-adapted
for the study of philosophy and he says
well why do you live then
if you don't care to live well and so
again
you know talking about priorities
another thing that he does that's quite
interesting diogenes
lived in a very simple way and he was
good with begging for or having people
giving him
food clothing there's a story about him
receiving a cloak
and then not giving it back and saying
listen if it was a gift
then i'm going to keep it if it was
alone i'm still using it but
food is another thing and there there's
a couple interesting
little quips about that
so he says being short of money he told
his friends he applied to them
not for alms but for repayment of his
due what does that mean they owe him
what do they owe him for the wonderful
company that he gives
no for teaching them for
helping them in a certain way a little
bit
later in diagenes laertes he says of
diogenes the cynic
um here we go
he begged alms of a statue and when
asked what he did to practice in being
refused right so that's an interesting
practice
in asking alms as he did at first by
reason of his poverty
he used this form if you have already
given to anyone else
give to me also if not begin with me and
so he's
providing you could say a short argument
a justification for
why somebody ought to feed him
out of their surplus he's also very
famous
for his responses to alexander the great
and as a matter of fact
outside of diogenes lieutenants there
are some texts that are
supposedly recording conversations
diogenes is having with alexander at
greater
length alexander macedon later alexander
the great
uh the conqueror of the persian empire
so
the first one i think many people are
quite familiar with um
when alexander uh shows
up um he's uh
asked you know the diogenes alexander
asks them do you need anything
and he says yes uh stand out of my light
and there's a lot of different
interesting twists
on this one that we can we could talk
about in other places
um another one that happens that's
quite famous as well here we go
he is
encountering alexander here we go
alexander once came and stood
opposite him and said i am alexander
the great king megas basileos right so
this is like you know i'm
i'm on top of the world and diogenes
responds
and i am diogenes the cynic and so you
say well
what's that about well each of them is
like putting their titles out there
and diogenes is in a certain way either
placing himself on the same level or
saying
listen buddy we're all down here even
though you're the great king
there's one other discussion of diogenes
and alexander as well
he says when alexander stood opposite
him and asked are you not afraid of me
now why would diogenes be afraid of him
well because
alexander had the power basically to put
anybody
to death or to do anything he wanted
right he's the great king
he says are you not afraid of me and
diogenes says well
why what are you are you a good thing or
a bad thing
and alexander says a good thing and so
damaging he says well who then is afraid
of the good
you know and the idea there is he's kind
of he's kind of ripping him a bit right
if you really are a good thing why would
i be scared of you
are you really a good thing alexander
right
there's also some really interesting
responses
where he's justifying his mode of living
as a cynic and so let's let's actually
work backwards in the text with these
so he says
he saw no impropriety either in stealing
anything from a temple
or eating the flesh of any animal nor
anything impious in touching human flesh
this he said being clear from the custom
of some
foreign nation so you know there's
nothing that's
really off limits except by
custom that we happen to have and
you know other other nations do these
sorts of things so that that's all right
um here's another
example being reproached for drinking in
a tavern he says
i also get my hair cut in a barber shop
and so
the the idea there is well there's
certain places where
why would you complain about me doing
that it'd be similar if you went to a
brothel and somebody's like
you're you know consorting with the
prostitutes what do you think of
brothels for you know
that's the whole point of that sort of
thing he didn't go to brothels
typically so
being reproached for eating in the
marketplace he says well it was in the
marketplace
that i felt hungry so within the
marketplace
this is where i'm going to satisfy my
hunger there's also
another very famous example of him
masturbating in the marketplace
and then saying if it was only so easy
to satisfy
hunger by rubbing your belly um
right that's that's another
justification of
his behavior instead of saying well this
is where i actually feel this he's
saying
wouldn't it be nice if things worked
this way
another great one is somebody reproached
him for his exile okay so
why would they make fun of him for that
being exiled was viewed as a bad thing
diogenes says
this is actually a great thing for me by
being
exiled i discovered philosophy by
philosophy
he doesn't just mean you know books
about philosophy he means
encountering somebody who could teach
him a way of
life and then he says when somebody
reminded him the people of cenopad had
sent
sentenced him to exile for you know
defacing the currency he says
i them to homestay another
example is provided um
yeah the marketplace idea right uh
masturbating in the marketplace we've
already discussed that one
and so he gives a lot of he uses his
freedom of speech
to justify his freedom of
action he also criticizes
others about their values and their
priorities
as being mistaken a theme we've brought
up already
and this is a quite important the cynic
is
viewed not just as somebody who's a
non-conformist but somebody who's
non-conformity
consists in showing another possible way
of life
so here's an example one day he was
was discoursing very seriously nobody
paid attention to him
he began whistling and then people
clustered about him
and he reproached them he says why are
you coming to listen to nonsense and not
paying attention
to serious discourse what is
wrong with you why don't you think about
that
and he doesn't spell it out completely
maybe
maybe he did in a serious discourse
though we don't really know
because we don't have the full record of
it just a a saying
he's got another great one at megara
where he saw the sheep protected by
leather jackets
and the children went bare he said it's
better to be a magarian's ram
than his son so he's saying you take
better care
of your sheep than you do your children
again what's
wrong with you is the implication there
what's wrong about your priorities
or your values another prime example
this is a great one although you know
you need to know a little bit of
cultural background to make this one
work
being asked by a tyrant what bronze is
best for a statue
he replied that of which harmonious
and arista guitar were molded now
what does that mean well those were
tyrant killers so if you're going to
make a statue for you the tyrant why
don't you make it out of the stuff
that was used to make statues for these
guys
or what it was that they were composed
of and maybe somebody will kill you
too you tyrant you no good person
another good example uh
here we go to a man who is urgently
pressing his suit to a courtesan he's
he's this is sort of a higher class
prostitute what we would nowadays call
like an escort or something
why are you at such pains to gain your
suit when it would be better for you
to actually lose it so
why are you pursuing this this person
and spending so much time so much money
so much attention on it
when you'd actually be better off using
that on other things
and that would happen if you actually
did lose your suit so
that's that's a key example he also had
some you know positive teachings and
these are another example
of panoracio he's got a there's a long
discussion here
about the need for discipline ascasis
in greek he says training was of two
kinds mentally and bodily the latter
being that whereby
with constant exercise perceptions are
formed such as secure
freedom of movement for virtuous deeds
the other half of this training is
incomplete without the other
good health and strength being just as
much included among the essential things
whether for body or soul
and so he's saying that you know this is
how we arrive at virtue
he's using his capacity to teach to tell
us how we ought to behave
and then he says nothing in life has any
chance of succeeding without strenuous
practice
this is capable of overcoming anything
and instead of useless efforts or toils
people should choose such as nature
recommends whereby they might have lived
happily and so you know there's a lot
more
to this this conversation uh which you
can find
but he's he's teaching you know some
some ideas
and he's doing so in kind of a public
way this may have been one of the things
where he's um telling people you need to
attend to my serious lectures
another thing that's really quite
interesting is
he's taken as a slave and this is very
common in the ancient world
there are a lot of ways to become a
slave and as a slave he tells people
when you know everybody is supposed to
instruct the you know what what am i
good for well i can wash dishes
i can be a gardener he says i'm the
person who's ready to rule
men so buy me as a slave
if you want a master so this is parasia
this is being in a very
difficult situation and saying something
that
could you know resound with the people
that are there so it says
yeah he says anybody should should buy
me if they want to purchase a
master to them for for themselves
zeniates purchased him and he said you
must obey me
although i am a slave why if a physician
or a steerman were in slavery he would
be obeyed what is he saying there he's
saying
you need to obey me for your own good
for your own safety that's why you've
in essence hired me and he
there's a discussion here about what he
teaches the sons
of geniundas and it's quite a curriculum
a very interesting thing discussed in
this
a little bit later in
the the work he says to zeniates who
purchased him he said come
see that you obey orders right
when he when he quoted the line back
where the streams flow to their fonts
diogenes asked
if you had been ill and had purchased a
doctor would you then instead of obeying
him have said that
um so you know that's
that's the idea there that that he's
using free speech once again to say
you need to listen to me i'm a
philosopher and philosophy can help you
understand your life the last thing that
i think we should close on
is his criticisms of something that's
kind of the opposite of freedom of
speech so in freedom of speech or
frankness of speech
you get to tell people how things are or
at least how you think they are
and you get to do so for their own good
and what's the opposite
of that well what he calls
um the greeks called flattery
and being a psychophant you know where
you're essentially telling people
lies about themselves or about where
they fit in
or whether they're good people or not in
order to
get something out of them so he's asked
what creatures what bite is the worst he
says
of those that are wild the psychophant
of those who are tame a
flatterers and then he says ingratiating
speech he compared to honey
used to choke you right so
he's contrasting this to the social
conventions of speaking at the time
which have people telling each other
pleasant lies
just to get by what we often call white
lies and he's saying no i'm not going to
be like that
my way of life demands that we call a
spade a spade that we
call a psychophanta psychophant that we
tell people you've got your priorities
all screwed up
and we use speech for the means
of producing a better more virtuous life
you